[Music]
SCOR Ambo this week we've got swim
commute boobie discount and AR implant
take it away Tiffany okay so far first
story there's this man who's went to
work every day instead of being stuck in
traffic
what that's so badass so he packs his
clothes like in a backpack and he jumps
in the water in a special bag meant for
like swimming yes oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
sick vessel smart what are you a robber
Cisco no Sweden is to pole being an
obvious loser in the UK no in Germany
what what does he do during the winter
when the like river is ice they just
walks over I slide Oh whole Sudan that
color is so [ __ ] full body condoms
that are raising vodka yeah it's a 40
year old Benjamin key swim this river
every day I don't know why I was
expecting a different body type like a
super skinny blender is a powder she
looks like a Neanderthal is really good
of Nike did he only swim like two feet
and you're not burning Amy calories no
he's possibly could have been way more
been a big also just floats across ten
she throws two kilometers you told his
bad like this and takes a little like so
why does he do that like what's his
reason so he says I he does it to avoid
all the traffic of his daily commute
because it's not as you'd be lucky
you'd be stuck in traffic for like the
entire morning so he's rather just have
that daily exercise going to work and he
just drive himself off he ends up
two-timing a coffee at a cafe near his
job and he just waits for all of his
co-workers to get to work wait so he
just got river water all over him and
she never Richard it off I mentor I hope
that rivers clean yeah it might be
different from our clay river water
it's like black walks on the work
smelling like piss and [ __ ] crack
rock yeah yeah we'll just swim back home
to God that's one that's more than a
mile to work and then afterwards another
mile going back home yeah I would just
be exhausted Wow you'd build it up I
guess so you're talking about facilities
how long is two kilometres it's over a
mile is it under two miles it's under
two miles is over model swimming that
far is pretty long yeah is your [ __ ]
long I could walk that that much that's
nothing but like swimming is a long time
yeah he's been doing a lot all years
naked
yo naked looks like his old bucket
operation he's really responsible though
every day before his commute or his swim
you he he checks online to make sure
that the temperatures by and that the
current is fine that everything's safe
and then that's when he knows he'll go
in the water
Easter sharks today no wait till he does
worse ensued and then he has his work
clothes on underneath no so in that bag
when you saw oh yeah this bag that he
carries it's like a like specially made
bag for people to carry their things
when there's one of us don't that's
super cool yeah he has like his laptop
in there and oh that's brave
so he's swimming with awake - yeah right
yeah over my tire and it just uses it
like a buoy
you call that cool yeah that looks fun
I'm kind of jealous
you could something Wow swim first and
then come here go to Le Figaro to work
yeah but that seems really fun oh yeah
doing this dude and how different is
commuted to work pretty cool and they
also talked about in this story how
there's this guy an element that takes a
plane to work every day to be works in
San Francisco oh I heard of that
really I heard a lot of business people
that have private planes and stuff like
they just go out there oh I got to go to
San Francisco after my lunch I have a
meeting there at 6:00 and then they fly
over there they do
meeting they come back Kobe Bryant does
stuff like that yeah it was in Newport
Beach she had the helicopter and he goes
in a trains basketball in El Segundo and
then he takes a helicopter attack every
day I mean that's where he wants to live
and work where he wants to work you have
that kind of money and freedom out I
mean I would do the exact same thing
everyone traffic yeah I want a hang
glider I want to drive two hours away
get on a hand glide and then get all the
way down to my your car that's realistic
yeah a little harder to get back to my
car over what in it but now you gotta
fold I hate gliders being into the
bucket uber car you have to be a truck
you didn't gallon through this okay so
partly for a second are you talking
about like ziplining me too with the
cable and yes my office in downtown LA
it's like yeah a guy that's always this
is the place that's just one guy you've
got like the goggles on having fun it so
serious well after a while every single
day you know you just cities are
detecting I know but what else will
happen you know sometimes you leave
something at home I remember one time I
sometimes I to barbell are you jog to
[ __ ] farm oh yeah what about that for
it's only two miles I know but I don't
know in my mind it was really far no it
feels that way until like after driving
and I looked at out like man I walked
more than this like in France or Japan
when we walk and just were just unaware
so I started jogging a barbell when I
got there I was like oh [ __ ] I totally
forgot like [ __ ] shoes my my like
squash rooms and all that ah see that it
does happen where you're like ha ha ha
I gotta go back and get it and I'm like
aw [ __ ] it I'll just squat barefoot or
something I gotta improvise you know but
that's what sucker you don't have a car
you can't just go back halfway through
alright for our next story there's this
restaurant that is offering discounts on
the food based on Bravo mmm awesome
there it does bigger than she / yes oh I
didn't even think that I thought I paid
good money I guess I thought I thought
this was a restaurant that sold bras -
so you could get your food and you get a
discount bra yeah that's what I was
thinking was going to go in that
direction - really no it makes sense
that's messed up so the bigger your
titties I suffer - of all with itty
bitty titties I am down that you know
what I'm a little salty Oh me and my boy
trip so what is how do they how do they
do any of our I wonder is there a waiter
that comes up and fills you up and says
okay you get 50 people say I know that's
what I have I will give them my broad be
like well is it your bra size or your
actual breasts I can easily wear a GG be
like Oh true right here you go
just a place entirely to like plan on it
it's an illusion you have like ten
chicken cutlets back though how about
three pretty key first of all you guys
want to guess where this takes place la
Dan oh why did I go for LA I really
thought Japan - but not a pan Russia
China China crime ah I'm surprised it
was China meat you know JD though don't
do sexual should don't but they're shady
so shut that is happening yeah I'm
probably picked out for me right there
yeah yeah so then they tell you the
price difference
why oh there's only one D what about the
double D's
probably maybe it's the FG I was there
you like double double J's and double
biggest different for free at that point
is if we food that's crazy
you need not this place I know is that
even good food yeah isn't worth it yeah
this mentioned I was a Chinese
restaurant I'm not sure if I had to get
to be Chinese food I never knew that
boobs were in in China because they like
girls that are like and I was like very
conservative Jenny I thought they were
always into like face it's pretty in
though if you watch the Chinese TV all
the commercials are always like these
creams that make your boobs bigger and
back of the newspapers like these pills
that make your boobs bigger this new soy
protein digestion oh you have any bodies
with big boobs yeah where do you watch
this because we don't watch that know
growing up David has like response being
Dre like like for your scalp with your
know that that's a thing in general
really right that when I was 14 it
didn't work so did I oh but it works not
that I didn't much conscious delayed it
was just a delayed reaction I bought
them I'm going to open up a restaurant
next to it this the booty thank you I
see I respect that
yeah I respect it - because that's what
I like
oh yes everybody's always you can grow
your butt do much about right I'm
getting sad slime up but a lot of people
are kind of angry about this because
they're saying that the posters were
vulgar advertised like it's probably
only just women in man know really
screwing or married men that the wives
are pushing yeah I meant to be pissed
yes could you imagine like a big ass
first woman comes in she gets it for
like three is it yen insurance I think
it come on I want you out and they're
like yeah you gotta you gotta pay full
price I'm like [ __ ] this place I'm
leaving like that would be so insulting
you watch all these big busted woman get
massive discounts and then you're paying
full price just because I'm really salty
what kind of reference what kind of
restaurant is this Chinese dish I mean
like what could you know what kind of
food Chinese visa I know I'm brown
Sakura I have know she that she said so
many times she doesn't know I'm not
[ __ ] around is it like in a main area
of trying to like is it like at a
downtown area
our editor feels my husband hangs out
I've heard of that one that's a pretty
mean City right
oh no I read are we gonna line the news
articles I'm assuming yeah that's like
what maybe like the San Francisco
California aliens maybe China doesn't
have the same like sexist discrimination
law things that we do you know maybe
they haven't they haven't evolved yet in
that aspect of this restaurant
understand though that they had their
customer numbers go up by 20 percent
since it also works yeah because the
thing is no matter how degrading agent
love discounts yeah so you can't they'll
be like I can't believe this [ __ ] while
they're stuffing the [ __ ] out of their
bras this is [ __ ] wrong Hong girls
yeah let's go get some food so that's
why I feel like in Asia like they don't
socially progress a lot because no
matter what all the businesses and
governments have to do is make a
discount and then people just say [ __ ]
my rights I'm getting this [ __ ] for
cheap you know I miss it it's actually a
shrimp restaurant
oh really that's worth it
in the restaurant he's losing residents
like bowling drivers if they did
something like this for me and they'll
be like all you got to do is do some
degrading [ __ ] like all guys with their
just dicks hanging out get a discount
I'll do it super down but they know guys
are gross yeah
what do you mean is what if something
guys will like go off I feel so like
humiliated like finger sticks finger in
your butthole all right who's got the
tighter butt hole gets the more discount
girl about to go fire if I view like I
have to go buy a car now and they're
like I'll give it to you for like
employee discount I just have to stick
my some money right now yeah any time I
get here you're [ __ ] yeah but that's
that's not more money it's for pleasure
I you know what I got a really tight
[ __ ] I'll get a huge discount you
know that I do you know it's like
because nothing will go inside no but
you could be having some massive shits
and you thought they could be sad
oh not your butt yeah you don't know
your butt I don't I don't hit but I
don't know my own butt I'm fine nothing
goes in there
it doesn't go in you've got a mistress
over it I tried this doesn't work so
what a straw doesn't work nothing else
yeah what if all right what if there's
an audience of old nasty like perverted
gay dudes that masturbate and watch you
while you're eating but you get a
discount but you got to be fully nude no
holy news for guys yeah ah come on the
food you would mind no no I'm just
saying like I'm just trying to picture
like what is the male equivalent I know
so you would mind in that is it
equivalent no I still don't I really I
feel like if I wasn't getting anything
out of it
I'll be like it'll make me uncomfortable
what if you're naked you have to get
naked and then there's a room full of a
bunch of hot girls just laughing and
putting me to shame
Oh that'll make me horny oh yeah I've
never just going to listen there's hot
girls that's it that's all you need I
don't think that's a fetish you know
that oh is that really girls
girls laughing at you dick yeah this is
the cottage for everything straight up
honestly it's like humiliation porn it's
like that stuff we're talking about
before where they like to have their
money taken from the river calm down -
yeah I watched when I was like oh my god
you've watched everything I want an
elastic never been a topic where he
doesn't know the porno forever
I'm not watching for like mm-hmm
pleasure I'm watching out of like wow
how did I get here and like who was a
guy that was like in a business suit and
there was like five girls just like
undressing him and laughing at him and
calling him little dick and all that
stuff and I'm like that would hurt my
feelings but it's also five hot girls so
I don't know how to like just make sure
take up more of your time I think during
your tour is telling I think
different call you at the end of the day
he was going to have sex like it was a
porno you know oh yeah so like well I
feel like it was like he gets a reward
either way he's going to get what he
wants with five girls well for the last
or which is nothing to do with anything
we've been talking about it there is
this company that they have created this
eye implant that they say that it can
possibly be sort of like an AR in your
eyes with an amp and our augmented
reality so like the over time even
though it all was a baby
what the AR because only AR I know is
the ar-15 huh I was thinking into a re
so how is that different from VR cuz
it's in your eyes you don't have the are
troopers but at the extra premiere you
guys this a little clip a lame so what
is virtual reality why is there a
bulbous straw going in an eyeball of it
I before God what the [ __ ]
oh who you have something like that I
should I do actually yeah
[Music]
Wow I like the music okay that's an eye
that's crossed what I have yeah whoa oh
my god that's dull okay yeah move on
honey
are you seeing a little grass on the
side there's grass and stuff yeah Dan
there's all kinds of different lenses
you could put in but I want you to
Graham filters so either dreamless be
unreasonable there's a football player
let's push opthamology player together
it's called Omega doesn't watch company
do it you don't get soon oh oh
so the way technology is going to say
not [ __ ] with mine I don't need
touching all dirty report where you have
like everything floating that already
exists crazy through your eyeball not I
meditate and I opened up my third eye
and I already know how to do that [ __ ]
really do right now how to close your
eyes all either meditate Ida meditate
I know okay in homeland oh wow I feel
like it's eventually going to get to a
point where you could like log into any
social media app and like watch any
movie all from your eyeball and like
you'll make a purchase I like yeah I
think yeah it reads it I'm down for all
of that [ __ ] is just I am NOT down to
put [ __ ] in my own body I don't have two
veins well you got boobies don't see my
goodreads are good day ah well that's
different because it's on a different so
this is on a layer of skin that I don't
give a [ __ ] about and then the boobies
is cuz I just said on pain this is are
you talking about technology yes
technology specifically so it's like I
don't want that [ __ ] I got it so you
don't mind getting like a big bowl of
putting on your live like that
stretching that out or whatever or like
stretching your neck yeah I guess I'm
not open to that level that's different
from putting a device yes
she want computers in my head yeah what
if the gender I in Izu sure I feel like
I'm like a hack and then yeah I'm scared
of making for mine I know that's why I
can't I can't like I just think to
myself like the government is involved
in everything yeah and one day they're
going to program your mind to make you
like go and do something horrible or be
a soldier and then there's new man your
bra control you all and then the people
who don't have the diviner to the bomber
no I will watch that you guys have to
have her demented but you guys know the
human mind is way more powerful than
anything so you can override that [ __ ]
and you can control them with your brain
but if if you're aware that you're in
control exactly because I already know
like I'm already like prepared I'm like
I'm gonna study with Tibetan monks and
I'm going to [ __ ] power charges [ __ ]
what they're ready what wait pause can
you pause that can you follow everyone
just imagine Joe homelessness [ __ ]
continue with a cape in cardboard box
but imagine there's a there's a computer
that they have prepared for the average
human mind they didn't prepare this ship
for the Dalai Lama
now the Dali Lama could go into
different galaxies and [ __ ] like that so
once I study other that homeboy that
comes in I'll be like tricky [ __ ] not
control you and I brought to you by
homeless yeah you guys aren't ready for
the future that's all I'm saying
we're not at all you're probably going
to outlive us jingle we have to be
honest I would watch a homeless Joe vlog
for sure yeah hey you guys want to stock
any of us we'll go ahead down to the
description box below and you can follow
us on Instagram and all kinds of stuff
for more videos
[Music]